programming throwdown episode 80 concurrency take it away jason hey everyone we're trying something new we have a couple of people already, which is really great. It's pretty cool that we got to sort of work out some of the kinks and things like that. And we were trying out Discord. So we have a Discord channel. You know, this is something that I've mentioned off and on for years and years. Basically, we have Facebook. We have a Google Plus page,
Programming Throwdown 第 80 期：并发。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，我们正在尝试一些新东西。已经有几个人加入了，这真的很棒。我们能解决掉一些小问题之类的，这感觉挺酷的。我们正在尝试使用 Discord，所以我们建立了一个 Discord 频道。你知道，这是我多年来一直断断续续提到的事情。基本上，我们有 Facebook，有 Google Plus 页面，
we have Twitter, we have all these different media, we have email, which is which is where we probably get most of our traffic. You know, we've all these different things. And people can't really talk to each other. Because if someone posts on Facebook, you know, they're only posting to one over n of the people, right? If someone emails us, you know, if someone posts on facebook you know they're only posting to one over n of the people right if someone emails us you know they can't other people can't respond to that right and so um with discord you know we're hoping that we can get something where um you know people can ask the one thing is you'll be able to listen to the show live which is pretty cool so we're actually broadcasting live on on discord um but then also like more importantly, people can ask questions.
我们有 Twitter，我们有各种不同的媒体，我们还有电子邮件，这可能是我们流量的主要来源。你知道，我们有所有这些不同的东西。但人们无法真正地互相交流。因为如果有人在 Facebook 上发帖，你知道，他们只是发给 n 分之一的人，对吧？如果有人给我们发邮件，你知道，如果有人在 Facebook 上发帖，你知道他们只是发给 n 分之一的人，对吧？如果有人给我们发邮件，你知道他们无法……其他人无法回复，对吧？所以，嗯，有了 Discord，你知道，我们希望能够实现一些功能，嗯，你知道，人们可以实时收听节目，这很酷，所以我们实际上是在 Discord 上进行直播，嗯，但更重要的是，人们可以提问。
We set up a little questions channel, um, and, uh, you know, we can answer them live or sometimes, you know, a lot of probably the majority of the questions we actually just email back that person and we don't really talk about it on the show. Um, we also get a lot of the same question. Um, you know, I think the most common question is, most common question is sort of like, should I go to college or should I do a nano degree and things like that? And we answer that directly to that person. And so this way, it's like if someone asks questions by default that go there, it can be seen by everyone. You can really help other people out with your question. Obviously, you know, our email still still works so email is not a problem but i figure we'll try this out we'll see how it goes new things are always yeah and actually patrick's on this which is that's
我们建立了一个小小的提问频道，嗯，而且，呃，你知道，我们可以现场回答，或者有时，你知道，可能大部分问题我们实际上只是给那个人回邮件，我们并没有在节目中讨论。嗯，我们也经常收到同样的问题。嗯，你知道，我认为最常见的问题是，最常见的问题有点像，我应该上大学还是应该读纳米学位之类的？我们直接回答那个人。所以这样的话，如果有人默认提出问题并发布在那里，每个人都能看到。你可以通过你的问题真正帮助到其他人。显然，你知道，我们的电子邮件仍然有效，所以电子邮件不是问题，但我认为我们会尝试一下，看看效果如何。新事物总是……是的，而且实际上 Patrick 也在上面，这是
one thing that separates this from from every other platform is is patrick himself is on this one well i am right now anyways you're pretty bearish on the discord i am bearish on social yeah anything yeah i uh i can understand that do you use uh slack at work probably not right no yeah makes sense cool well let's i used walk over to people's desks and then reminded why i went to the same office that's a good point i am somebody the other day who is like literally just a foot away and i kind of realized wait a minute i should just talk to this person um so yeah we'll just jump right into it so uh my first news article is 15 years of spark fun so spark fun's an awesome website they do a bunch of really cool projects um my guess is i know they have a store too right so if you want to buy like a i don't know a linear servo or something like
将此与其他所有平台区分开来的一点，就是 Patrick 本人也在上面。好吧，反正我现在在上面。你对 Discord 相当看空。我对社交媒体看空。是的，任何东西。是的，呃，我可以理解。你在工作中用 Slack 吗？可能不用吧，对吧？不，是的，有道理。酷，好吧，让我们……我过去常走到人们的办公桌前，然后提醒自己为什么要去同一个办公室。这是一个很好的观点。我前几天遇到一个人，他简直就在一英尺远的地方，我突然意识到，等一下，我应该直接和这个人说话。嗯，所以是的，我们直接进入正题吧。所以，呃，我的第一条新闻是 SparkFun 成立 15 周年。所以 SparkFun 是一个很棒的网站，他们做了很多非常酷的项目。我的猜测是，我知道他们也有商店，对吧？所以如果你想买一个，我不知道，线性伺服电机之类的
that or arduino board they sell them there um they sell some really cool kind of battery um you know different form factors of batteries and things like that um but the thing they're most known for is just having really cool articles and and having really cool how-tos and things like that and they're celebrating 15 years which is which is which is really neat so not only is this article just a yay type article but also they they really go through and document the entire 15 years. And they're very candid about, you know, this is year one. I don't remember exactly who started it, but the person who was writing this, like, this is year one. I'm by myself, like in my basement, starting SparkFun. And they go through kind of the whole evolution of of spark fun so it's pretty cool to read
或者 Arduino 开发板，他们那里有卖。他们卖一些非常酷的电池，嗯，你知道，不同外形的电池之类的。嗯，但他们最出名的是拥有非常酷的文章和非常酷的操作指南之类的东西。他们正在庆祝 15 周年，这真的很棒。所以这篇文章不仅是一篇庆祝文章，而且他们还真正地回顾并记录了这 15 年的全部历程。他们非常坦诚，你知道，这是第一年。我不记得确切是谁创办的，但写这篇文章的人说，这是第一年。我一个人，在我的地下室里，创办了 SparkFun。他们回顾了 SparkFun 的整个演变过程，所以读起来很酷。
yeah so hobbyist electronics components that's how i would describe it but yeah specializing in having a really good documentation instead of obscure data sheets yep yeah it totally makes sense that's crazy about 15 years i don't even think i i don't even know when i was the first customer it was early but it wasn't 15 years ago yeah it's wild i had no idea that they had been around that long i didn't get into robotics till very very late so uh um yeah for me it's the first thing i bought was maybe a year ago or something but uh yeah it was really cool. Now I'm curious.
是的，所以业余电子元件，这就是我会形容它的方式，但确实，他们专注于拥有非常好的文档，而不是晦涩难懂的数据表。是的，是的，15 年了，这太疯狂了。我甚至不认为……我甚至不知道我什么时候是第一个客户，那是很早以前，但不是 15 年前。是的，这太疯狂了。我根本不知道他们已经存在那么久了。我直到非常非常晚才接触机器人技术，所以，嗯，是的，对我来说，我买的第一件东西可能是大约一年前，或者类似的时间，但，嗯，是的，这真的很酷。现在我很好奇。
I'm going to go search my email and figure out when the first time I bought something from them was. It's going to take a while. I'll do my new story instead. So my new story is building a CPU in the web browser. This is something I ran across. I think it was on Hacker News where someone was doing a show, Hacker News,
我要去搜索我的电子邮件，找出我第一次从他们那里买东西是什么时候。这需要一点时间。我先讲我的新闻故事吧。所以我的新闻故事是在网页浏览器中构建一个 CPU。这是我偶然发现的东西。我想是在 Hacker News 上，有人在做展示，Hacker News，
and they were, I guess, practicing their web skills. But I did play this for a while and I found it pretty interesting. And so this is, we've talked about, I believe, NAND to Tetris before, which is a similar idea, starting with the lowest level gates and building up more complex digital logic gates and all the way up until you have a processor and NAND to Tetris even sort of programming the processor and going onward
而且他们，我想，是在练习他们的网页技能。但我确实玩了一会儿，觉得它非常有趣。所以这是，我们之前讨论过，我相信，NAND to Tetris，这是一个类似的想法，从最低级的逻辑门开始，构建更复杂的数字逻辑门，一直到你拥有一个处理器，NAND to Tetris 甚至还在某种程度上对处理器进行编程并继续前进
and upward. But this one, I think, stopped short of that. I didn't do all of the from scratch. I did get, I think, to all the way through the adder. So starting with, I believe you start with a NOR gate. So using a NOR gate, building up all the other gates, building up various logic components, and then an adder. Nice.
和向上。但这个，我想它在那个阶段之前就停止了。我没有做所有从零开始的部分。我想我确实一直做到了加法器。所以从，我相信你从一个 NOR 门开始。所以使用一个 NOR 门，构建所有其他门，构建各种逻辑组件，然后是一个加法器。不错。
And they have a little playground canvas that you can drag components on to build them and then once you sort of unlock a new component then you your sort of next lesson uses that or is allowed to use that component um and so if you're interested in that kind of thing and want a super low barrier to entry uh just you can head on over to nandgame.com or we'll have a link in the show notes and you can try that out yeah very cool i played um i think it was human resource manager something like that yeah we made it yeah i made it a tool to show one show and that was very very satisfying and so yeah i'll give this a shot i think those games are just are, super fun. Because it's like, it's the idea of, you know, I built something,
他们有一个小小的游乐场画布，你可以把组件拖到上面去构建它们，然后一旦你解锁了一个新组件，你的下一课就会使用它，或者被允许使用该组件。嗯，所以如果你对这类事情感兴趣，并且想要一个超低的入门门槛，呃，你可以直接前往 nandgame.com，或者我们会在节目笔记中提供链接，你可以尝试一下。是的，非常酷。我玩过，嗯，我想是 Human Resource Machine 之类的。是的，我们做到了。是的，我做了一个工具来展示一个节目，那非常非常令人满足。所以是的，我会试一试，我认为那些游戏只是，超级有趣。因为这就像，这是关于，你知道，我构建了某个东西，
and then I am now able to sort of replicate that thing. And then you end up with, like, so many layers of indirection. So you have this really complex web. It's just really cool to watch. Yeah. So this one's a little less polished from a UI standpoint than something like the Human Resource game, or is there something like TIS
然后我现在能够某种程度上复制那个东西。然后你最终会得到，像，这么多层的间接引用。所以你拥有这个非常复杂的网络。看着它真的很酷。是的。所以这个从 UI 的角度来看比像 Human Resource 游戏，或者像 TIS
8000 or Shenzhen IO there's a couple of others that are in similar veins this one's a little less it's somebody mostly just sort of practicing well I don't, not to be offensive but from the way I understood the way it was posted it was someone sort of learning to do a sort of web app
8000 或 Shenzhen IO 那样的游戏稍微没那么精致，还有其他几个类似的。这个稍微没那么……这主要是某人在练习，好吧，我不是，不是要冒犯，但从我理解它发布的方式来看，这是某人在学习如何做一个网页应用，
but they made something that was pretty cool and doing it. Nice. My next one is, again, about Discord, why Discord is sticking with React Native. And, yeah, this was super interesting. So basically, for people who don't know, React Native is a way where you write JavaScript in HTML.
但他们做了一些非常酷的东西。不错。我的下一个话题，同样是关于 Discord，为什么 Discord 坚持使用 React Native。而且，是的，这非常有趣。所以基本上，对于不知道的人来说，React Native 是一种让你用 HTML 写 JavaScript 的方式。
Actually, they call it, I think, RSX or something like that, but it looks a lot like HTML. And basically, it will sort of transpile that into an app. Like it will basically distill that down into a native app. And so in this React Native system, you say I have a button and I have a label, et cetera, et cetera. And then you say, okay, I want an iOS app.
实际上，他们称之为，我想是 RSX 之类的，但它看起来很像 HTML。基本上，它会某种程度上将它转译成一个应用。就像它基本上会把它提炼成一个原生应用。所以在这个 React Native 系统中，你说我有一个按钮，我有一个标签，等等等等。然后你说，好的，我想要一个 iOS 应用。
And it goes and does all sorts of magic and you end up with an iOS app that is native. So it's, as opposed to something like Unity, where you're manipulating basically individual pixels on the screen. And so if you make a button, you know, it's going to look exactly the same on everyone's phone, like pixel for pixel. But that's not really what people want. What people want is, you know, if they're on iOS, they want it to feel like an iOS app
然后它会做各种魔法，你最终会得到一个原生的 iOS 应用。所以它，与像 Unity 那样的东西相反，你在那里基本上是在操纵屏幕上的单个像素。所以如果你制作一个按钮，你知道，它在每个人的手机上看起来都会完全一样，像素对像素。但那并不是人们真正想要的。人们想要的是，你知道，如果他们在 iOS 上，他们希望它感觉像一个 iOS 应用，
and the same for Android, right? Also, you know, an incredible amount of work has gone into making those buttons and those text boxes and making sure the keyboard doesn't pop over the text box and all of that stuff, right? And you don't want to reinvent all of that. That would be very tough. So, and even if you did,
Android 也是一样，对吧？而且，你知道，为了制作那些按钮和文本框，并确保键盘不会弹到文本框上方以及所有这些东西，已经投入了难以置信的工作量，对吧？你不想重新发明所有这些。那会非常困难。所以，即使你做了，
it wouldn't be like the one people are used to, right? So React Native kind of gets around a lot of that. I mean, it's not a silver bullet, right? So, for example, if the keyboard just interacts differently with text boxes on one platform and the other, then it could be on Android. You're covering up a text box with a keyboard, and it's really ugly but on ios you're not and so you have to sort of finagle all of that so that you get something that looks nice on everything um and so this uh this article is just all about a team doing that and and uh um and that whole experience so they kind of document their whole uh journey with react native so i thought that was pretty
它也不会是人们习惯的那种，对吧？所以 React Native 在很大程度上绕过了这些。我的意思是，它不是万能药，对吧？所以，例如，如果键盘在不同平台上的交互方式与文本框不同，那么它可能在 Android 上。你用键盘遮住了文本框，这真的很丑，但在 iOS 上你不会，所以你必须某种程度上调整所有这些，以便你在所有东西上都能得到看起来不错的东西。嗯，所以这个，这篇文章就是关于一个团队在做这件事，以及，嗯，以及整个体验。所以他们某种程度上记录了他们与 React Native 的整个旅程，所以我认为这非常
cool i feel like there's been a sequence of these kinds of things i don't remember all the names their whole journey with React Native. So I thought that was pretty cool. I feel like there's been a sequence of these kinds of things. I don't remember all the names because I don't do really mobile programming, but the React one seems to have stuck around for a while. I don't know if it's stuck around quote-unquote long, but it seems like it's been a thing for longer than average.
酷。我觉得已经有一系列这样的东西了，我不记得所有的名字，他们与 React Native 的整个旅程。所以我认为这非常酷。我觉得已经有一系列这样的东西了。我不记得所有的名字，因为我真的不做移动编程，但 React 这个似乎已经存在了一段时间。我不知道它是否算“长久”，但它似乎比平均水平存在的时间更长。
There was like Xamarin was a big thing, and there was PhoneGap, where it was literally a webpage. that one um yeah and a lot of these kind of died out um it seems like react native for whatever reason has just stuck so i found my first spark fun order oh nice what time what uh year do you want to guess i'll take a shot how many years ago i'm gonna guess that you needed it for some college project and so i'm told oh we can't disclose how long ago rat you out but okay let me just loosely guess i'm gonna guess around um like 12 years ago. Oh, that's a good guess. Oh, nice. 11 years ago. Nice.
曾经有像 Xamarin 这样的东西，还有 PhoneGap，它字面上就是一个网页。那个，嗯，是的，很多这些都消失了。看起来 React Native 不知何故坚持了下来。所以我找到了我的第一笔 SparkFun 订单。哦，不错。你猜猜是什么年份？我会试一试。多少年前？我猜你是因为某个大学项目需要它，所以我被告知，哦，我们不能透露多久以前，免得告发你，但好吧，让我随便猜猜。我猜大约是，嗯，12 年前。哦，那是个好猜测。哦，不错。11 年前。不错。
Yeah. It was not for a school project. Oh, really? Oh, okay. I actually can see what I ordered, and I know what I did with them. Oh, okay. All right. So it was actually, well, anyways, I'm not going to age myself.
是的。那不是为了学校项目。哦，真的吗？哦，好吧。我实际上可以看到我订购了什么，而且我知道我用它们做了什么。哦，好吧。好吧。所以它实际上是，嗯，无论如何，我不会暴露我的年龄。
All right. I ended up using Arduino to build a little thing that moved around on stepper motors. Oh, nice. Actually, speaking of that, my chess robot arm, I'm making good progress there. I'm posting on Facebook if anyone is following me there, but not as the podcast. You have to follow me because I want to keep the podcast pretty high signal to noise. But yeah, the robot arm is uh is pretty good i have a little stepper motor i'm actually looking at it right now and it moves i don't know this
好吧。我最终使用 Arduino 构建了一个在步进电机上移动的小东西。哦，不错。实际上，说到这个，我的国际象棋机械臂，我在那里取得了很好的进展。如果有人在 Facebook 上关注我，我会在那里发布，但不是以播客的名义。你必须关注我，因为我想保持播客的高信噪比。但是的，机械臂，嗯，相当不错。我有一个小步进电机，我实际上现在正看着它，它在移动。我不知道这个
probably isn't a good design but you know it works like basically i have a platform that goes up and down or i guess left and right and then that figures out which column to go the arm should pick from. And then the arm only has to think about one axis then. Oh, that's nice. Yeah, so it seems to work pretty well. I mean, it's not as fast, I think, as having an arm that could swing around. I mean, it just needs to work. Yeah. I mean, for me, this is a huge accomplishment
可能不是一个好的设计，但你知道，它有效。基本上，我有一个上下移动的平台，或者我猜是左右移动，然后它计算出机械臂应该从哪一列拾取。然后机械臂只需要考虑一个轴。哦，那很好。是的，所以它似乎工作得很好。我的意思是，我认为它不像拥有一个可以四处摆动的机械臂那么快。我的意思是，它只需要工作。是的。我的意思是，对我来说，这是一个巨大的成就，
because I actually burnt a motherboard or melted – not a motherboard. I melted a breadboard because no one told me that you're not supposed to put seven amps melted a breadboard because uh no one told me that you're not supposed to put seven amps through a breadboard and uh wait yeah how did you manage to even have something that could do seven amps uh well i have the the stepper maybe it's not seven but i have the stepper motor and i have a digital servo and the digital servo is for the shoulder of the robot so so i got one that's pretty powerful.
因为我实际上烧坏了一个主板，或者熔化了——不是主板。我熔化了一个面包板，因为没有人告诉我你不应该把 7 安培的电流通过面包板，而且，呃，等等，是的，你是怎么设法拥有一个能达到 7 安培的东西的？嗯，我有步进电机，也许不是 7 安培，但我有步进电机，我有一个数字伺服电机，数字伺服电机是用于机器人的肩膀的，所以我买了一个功率相当大的。
And basically, yeah, if I have the platform moving and I try to move the arm at the same time, it draws a lot. Like, I don't know if it's exactly seven amps, but it's a lot of amps. It's not seven amps. It's definitely... You can't run seven amps through the PCB wiring. Oh, really? Oh, okay. That's not seven.
基本上，是的，如果我让平台移动，并且我尝试同时移动机械臂，它会消耗很多电流。就像，我不知道它是否正好是 7 安培，但它是很多安培。它不是 7 安培。它绝对是……你不能通过 PCB 布线运行 7 安培。哦，真的吗？哦，好吧。那不是 7 安培。没关系。
It's okay. I won't be nerdy. the pcb wiring oh really oh okay that's not seven it's okay it's it's enough well the breadboard can handle half an amp and i melted the breadboard so it's it's more than that so you are somewhere over half an amp that's my lower and upper bound uh okay well cool yeah don't don't don't burn your house down though man i'll try my best you know it's it's proving to be pretty difficult not to burn my house down also yeah you probably I'll try my best. You know, it's proving to be pretty difficult not to burn my house down. Also, yeah, you probably want to look at like motor drivers or adding a transistor so that it drives directly
没关系。我不会表现得太书呆子气。PCB 布线，哦，真的吗？哦，好吧，那不是 7 安培。没关系，它足够了。好吧，面包板可以处理半安培，但我熔化了面包板，所以它超过了那个数值，所以你是在半安培以上，这是我的下限和上限。呃，好吧，酷。是的，别，别，别把你的房子烧了，伙计。我会尽力的。你知道，事实证明，不把我的房子烧掉是相当困难的。另外，是的，你可能，我会尽力的。你知道，事实证明，不把我的房子烧掉是相当困难的。另外，是的，你可能想看看像电机驱动器或者添加一个晶体管，这样它直接从电源驱动，
from the power supply instead of running through the Arduino, if that's what it's doing. Yeah, I got... So basically... Okay, you already do that. Yeah, the breadboard is only there because I don't have a way to splice wires. So it's literally... You don't have a sold to splice wires so it's literally you don't
而不是通过 Arduino 运行，如果它是在那样做的话。是的，我得到了……所以基本上……好的，你已经那样做了。是的，面包板只是因为我没有办法拼接电线。所以它字面上是……你没有焊接来拼接电线，所以它字面上是……你
have a soldering iron i oh when's your birthday i'll send you one i actually have a soldering iron i never even uh um oh no actually it's uh i don't have sorry i have the split what i don't have is the um i would need to take a regular wire and basically put the right adapter on it so i could plug it in or you could just cut off the adapter i mean i yes i run into this all the time this is a horrible habit i just end up cutting off whatever adapter and just soldering on whatever oh man that is so smart so like oh i have a power plug that has this barrel jack and i need to feed it into my arduino like asker it i just snip off the barrel jack and then ta-da wires yeah that's really smart i should have thought about that no it's not smart no i mean it's it's resourceful or whatever i never
没有烙铁。我，哦，你什么时候生日？我给你寄一个。我实际上有一个烙铁，我从来没有，呃，嗯，哦不，实际上是，呃，我没有，抱歉，我有那个分线器，我没有的是，嗯，我需要拿一根普通的电线，基本上装上正确的适配器，这样我就可以插上它，或者你可以直接剪掉适配器。我的意思是，是的，我一直遇到这种情况。这是一个糟糕的习惯，我最终只是剪掉任何适配器，然后焊接上任何东西。哦，伙计，这太聪明了。所以，哦，我有一个带有桶形插孔的电源插头，我需要把它喂给我的 Arduino，像 asker 一样，我只是剪掉桶形插孔，然后哒哒，电线。是的，这真的很聪明，我应该想到这一点。不，这不聪明。不，我的意思是，这很机智或者什么的，我从来
would have thought of that yeah okay um yeah so just remember i mean you're hacking so you you can just cut off whatever you can't connect to yeah one of the things as long as if you don't need it back again yeah exactly one of the things i'm having a hard time being destructive but then it's like i bought this stuff to make this one thing so i need to just get over that yeah okay soldering yeah the next fun here i want to know when you're making your own pcbs yeah i'll call you when i get my fingers stuck together wait what super glue solder i don't know well solder is not that sticky but solder is super hot and i don't know all right next topic we're talking
不会想到这一点。是的，好的，嗯，是的，所以记住，我的意思是，你是在黑客攻击，所以你，你可以直接剪掉任何你无法连接的东西。是的，其中一件事，只要如果你不需要它回来。是的，完全正确。其中一件事，我很难做到具有破坏性，但后来就像，我买了这些东西来制作这个东西，所以我需要克服这一点。是的，好的，焊接。是的，下一个有趣的事情，我想知道你什么时候制作自己的 PCB。是的，当我把手指粘在一起时我会给你打电话。等等，什么？强力胶，焊料，我不知道。好吧，焊料没那么粘，但焊料超级热，我不知道。好吧，下一个话题，我们正在谈论
about fortnite fortnite's popular we talk about whatever's popular like cryptocurrency was popular so we talked about now i hear fortnight's popular yeah it's just seo seo baby do you play have you seen a baby i have played it's i ain't gonna lie it seems too complicated you know what i i feel the same way and the only thing i like i know granted i've only played a little bit but i like the 50 verse 50 have you tried that uh no i like i've played it literally three times i think yeah me it's not that much different for me but but uh uh they have this mode where it's it's just like pub g and that it's it's it's 100 players but it's literally two teams of 50 um you know it's pretty fun i'm sure everyone's laughing because they've probably all played it before oh sorry no no i mean basically the thing about 50 on 50 is you have
Fortnite。Fortnite 很受欢迎，我们谈论任何流行的东西，就像加密货币曾经很流行，所以我们谈论了它。现在我听说 Fortnite 很流行。是的，这只是 SEO，SEO 宝贝。你玩过吗？你见过吗？我玩过，我不会撒谎，它看起来太复杂了。你知道吗，我也有同样的感觉，唯一我喜欢的，我承认我只玩了一点点，但我喜欢 50 对 50。你试过那个吗？呃，不，我喜欢，我字面上只玩了三次，我想。是的，对我来说没什么不同，但，呃，呃，他们有这个模式，它就像 PUBG，它是 100 名玩家，但它字面上是两队 50 人，嗯，你知道，这很有趣。我相信每个人都在笑，因为他们可能都玩过。哦，抱歉，不，不，我的意思是，基本上关于 50 对 50 的事情是，你对游戏结果的控制力很小，但，呃，我觉得它很有趣。是的，他们赚了十亿，我会试试那个。哇，所以我是在我的 iPad 上玩的，我发现跑步和射击还可以，嗯，我之前试过 PUBG，我玩得更多一点，嗯，但建筑我发现非常困难。哦，好的，明白了。所以我注意到，我不知道人们怎么……而且这只是因为我玩得不够多，有些人有一种方法可以建造像整个塔楼一样的东西。我不知道他们是否像，你知道，使用某种宏，就像，你知道，在输入级别，或者 Fortnite 中是否有一个我不知道的设置，或者只是，好吧，是的，好吧，显然你和我是在座唯一不知道的人，因为 Fortnite 自从十月推出以来已经赚了十亿美元，所以他们是从某个地方得到那笔钱的。人们
very little control of the outcome of the game but uh i thought it was it was pretty fun yeah they made a billion i'll try that wow so i played it on my ipad and i found the uh running and shooting was fine um and i've tried pubg before i played that a little more um but the building i found very difficult oh okay got it so i noticed that i don't know how people um and this is just because i haven't played enough some people have a way to build like entire towers i don't know if they're like you know using some kind of macro like you know at an input level or if there's just a setting in fortnite that i don't know about or just well yeah well apparently you and i are the only people who don't know because fortnite has made a billion dollars since launching in october so they are getting that money from somewhere people are
在玩它，这是一回事。呃，甚至，你知道，某种非传统的游戏玩家也在玩它。我当时在听一些播客，我想可能是 TWiT，我很少听那个，我不听很多播客，但我出于某种原因听了一个，嗯，他们谈论这是一个有趣的现象，人们越来越多地专门玩特定的游戏。所以像，我不是游戏玩家，我玩 Fortnite，我玩英雄联盟，我玩 Dota，就像，我不玩。过去人们只是玩任何游戏，任何游戏出来，任何游戏是新的，但现在越来越多的人只玩 Minecraft，只玩 Fortnite，你
playing it it's a thing uh even you know sort of non-traditional gamers have been playing that i was listening to some podcasts i think it might have been twit which i listen to very rarely i don't listen to a lot of podcasts but i was listening to one for some reason and um they were speaking about that this is an interesting phenomenon where people are increasingly specializing into like specific games so something like i'm not a gamer i play fortnite i play league of legends i play dota like like i don't play it used to be people would just play whatever games whatever game was out whatever game was new but now there's increasingly people who just play minecraft just play fortnite you
知道吗，就像，他们某种程度上观察到他们的许多朋友和熟人只玩一款游戏。哇，这真的很有趣。所以我不知道这是否，我不知道这是否属实。我确实在某种程度上体验过这一点，就像我认识一些在工作的人，他们某种程度上总是玩同样的游戏。呃，守望先锋，是那个吗？哦，是的，守望先锋，那是其中之一。是的，所以很多这些，呃，在线多人游戏，他们玩得非常排他。这有道理，我的意思是，在某种程度上，它就像国际象棋之类的，或者和你的朋友玩扑克之类的，就像，你不会去扑克之夜，然后决定玩，我不知道，像，呃，拉米纸牌之类的，他们总是玩扑克。也许你不会掷骰子来看看我们今天要玩什么纸牌游戏。卡坦岛定居者，等等，我以为这是扑克之夜。
know what like they they were sort of observing that a lot of their friends and acquaintances only play a single game wow it's really interesting so i don't know if that's i don't know if that's true i i do experience that somewhat like i know some people at work who are sort of always playing the same game uh overwatch is that is that oh yeah overwatch that's one of them yeah so a lot of these uh online multiplayer games uh they play very exclusively that makes sense i mean at some point it's like chess or something or playing you know poker with your friends or something where it's like you don't go to poker night and decide to play i don't know like uh rummy or something they just always play poker maybe you don't let's roll the die to see what card game we're gonna play today sellers of Catan wait I thought this was Pokernet
酷，所以现在是节目推荐书的时间。我的节目推荐书是一个播客，但我一直，与听有声读物相反，这是我通常做的，
cool so now it's time for book of the show of the show my book of the show is a podcast but I've been as opposed to listening to audio books which is what I usually do
这个月我只是狂听了这个播客，我觉得它很棒。它叫《亲爱的哈佛商业评论》或《亲爱的 HBR》。所以我实际上对哈佛商业评论了解不多。就像我不知道它与大学的具体隶属关系。但它是什么，只是研究，嗯，商业的社会部分的人。所以你记得在上一集中，我们谈到了技术论点，嗯，这些人只是专注于，嗯，只是，嗯，在公司内部工作，甚至为你自己工作，或者其他什么。
this month I just binged on this podcast and I thought it was great. It's called Dear Harvard Business Review or Dear HBR. So I don't actually know too much about Harvard Business Review. Like I don't know exactly how it's affiliated with the university. But what it is, is just people who study, um, the, the, the social part of businesses. So you remember in the last episode, we talked about technical arguments and, um, these people just focus on, um, just the, the in and outs of, of, of working with, with in a company or even for yourself or what have you.
而且，嗯，呃，你知道，每一集都专注于一个特定的主题。嗯，所以有一集是关于糟糕的老板，还有另一集是关于糟糕的下属，而且，嗯，他们接听电话，嗯，实际上他们接听，我想是来自观众的电子邮件，并回答他们的问题。他们还邀请专家，你知道，嗯，作者，人们，社会科学家，你知道，研究过，嗯，你知道，像行业，你知道，以及那种，你知道，企业文化以及所有这些的人，而且，嗯，这真的很酷。我实际上有点，我完全狂听了它。我看了，嗯，大概 12 集，它简直太迷人了。所以，去看看吧。我的节目推荐书是一个科幻小说推荐，而且我们之前有这位作者，但那是约翰·斯卡尔齐的《老人的战争》。而且我决定做一些不同的事情，因为
And, um, uh, you know, each episode focuses on a particular topic um so there's one episode there's a bad bosses there's another episode that was bad uh reports and and uh and they take calls um from actually they take i guess emails from the audience and uh answer their questions they also bring on experts um you know um authors uh people who social scientists you know people have studied um you know uh like industry you know and that sort of you know corporate culture and all of that and uh it was really cool i actually kind of i totally binged on it i watched um probably 12 episodes and it was just super fascinating so so check it out my book of the show is a science fiction recommendation um and we've had this author before but that's john scalzi's old man's war uh and i decided to do something different because
我总是努力不剧透，所以我只是要读，好吧，我会说书的背面，但我只是要读亚马逊上的摘要。约翰·佩里在他的 75 岁生日那天做了两件事。首先，他参观了他妻子的坟墓，然后他加入了军队。哦，不错，那是一个很好的引子。我知道，是的，所以如果你是那些喜欢前一两三句话的人之一，那是写《红衫》的作者吗？《红衫》。此外，我们还谈到了《被锁住》，我想，在这个节目中我推荐过。我还读了他的《毛茸茸的国家》，这实际上是他重写的一本更古老的书，
i always struggle to not give spoilers so i'm just gonna read well i would say the back of the book but i'm just gonna read the summary from amazon uh john perry did two things on his 75th birthday first he visited his wife's grave then he joined the army oh nice that's a good lead-in i know yeah so if you're one of those people who enjoys the first one two three sentences is that the author who did Red Shirts? Red Shirts. Also, we've talked about Locked In, I think, on this show that I recommended. I also read from him Fuzzy Nation, which is actually him rewriting a much older book,
但我不知道我是否在这个节目中把它作为节目推荐书提到过。无论如何，所以《老人的战争》，我读了大约三分之二，而且，呃，到目前为止我非常喜欢它。而且我相信它已经变成了一个系列，有像七八本书，就像系列中有很多书，但这是第一本，而且我刚刚开始读它，而且，呃，到目前为止，我很喜欢它。正如那三句话所说，关于如果老年人会是什么样子，以及为什么老年人会去打仗，有一些有趣的假设。
but I don't know if I've mentioned it as a book of the show on this episode. Anyway, so Old Man's War, I'm about two-thirds of the way through and uh so far i very much enjoyed it uh and i believe it's turned into a series that has like a bunch of books like seven or eight books like a lot of books in the series but this is the first one and i'm i've just started it and uh so far i'm enjoying it it as the three sentences said there's some interesting premises about what would it be like if old people and why would old people go to war
所以，但是的，你读了。我读了，我觉得它非常有趣，它非常有趣，绝对不是侵犯商标的《星际迷航》故事。是的，那是对的。我的意思是，我通常只是喜欢模仿，对吧？因为我喜欢，嗯，某人，基本上，因为你真的必须提炼
so but yeah you read I did I thought it was really interesting it was really fun the definitely not trademark infringing Star Trek story yeah that's right I mean i in general i just love parodies right because i love um somebody basically you because you really have to distill
某样东西来模仿它。所以，呃，对于那些在 Audible 上的人，因为我有通勤时间，所以我花了很多时间听有声读物，读完相当多，而且我总是用 Audible 听它们。如果你想支持这个节目，而且，呃，你有兴趣尝试听一本免费的有声读物，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得一个免费的一个月会员资格，这给你一本免费的书，一个书的积分。对我来说，我总是试图优化选书，这本《老人的战争》到目前为止是一本很棒的书。
something down to to parody it and so uh in to those on audible because i have a commute and so i spend a lot of time listening to audiobooks um get through a fair number of them and i always listen to them on audible and if you would like to support the show and uh you would be interested in trying to listen to a free audiobook, you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown and you can get a free one-month membership, which gives you a free book, one credit for a book. And for me, I'm always trying to optimize picking a book, which Old Man's War is a great book so far.
我认为如果你不习惯听很多书，这是一个不错的选择，但我通常尝试追求性价比，寻找非常长的书。而且我觉得我从我的积分中获得了更好的价值，因为基本上所有的书都是这样定价的。是的。但我们在节目笔记中有一长串推荐，
I think it would be good to pick up if you're not used to listening to a lot of books, but I normally try to go for sort of bang for the buck and look for books that are really long. And I feel like I get a better value for my credit because basically all the books are kind of priced this. Yeah. But we have a whole litany of recommendations through the show notes of
Jason 和我都推荐过，可以在 Audible 上找到。所以去看看吧。是的。另一件事，我开始，呃，在 Google Play 上听播客，至少在 Android 上，Google Play 应用有各种各样的问题。就像我不知道这是否是那个播客特有的，但基本上，嗯，会发生什么，如果你暂停它然后恢复，它会重新开始。我不知道为什么。实际上，现在我想起来了，有人给我们发邮件说我们的播客也发生了这种情况。我认为这只是 Google Play 的一个问题，但事实证明 Audible 上也有播客。所以你实际上可以在 Audible 上获得《亲爱的 HBR》和其他播客。
various books that both Jason and I have recommended that are available on audible. So check it out. Yeah. other thing i started uh listening to the podcast um on google play and at least on android um the google play app has all sorts of issues like i don't know if it was specific to that podcast but basically um what would happen is if you would pause it and then resume it would would start over. I don't know why. Actually, now I think about it, someone emailed us saying that that happens to our podcast. I think it's just an issue with Google Play, but it turns out there's also podcasts on Audible. And so you can actually get Dear HBR and other podcasts on Audible.
只要你有订阅，它们就不花钱。而且如果你已经有了 Audible 订阅，它的用户界面比 Google Play 好得多。哦，我不知道。是的。酷。如果你不想在 Audible 上支持我们，你要么已经有了 Audible 账户，要么你想以另一种方式支持我们，你可以看看我们的 Patreon。
They don't cost any money as long as you have a subscription. And if you already have an Audible subscription, it's a much better user interface than the Google Play. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. Cool. If you don't want to support us on Audible, you either already have an Audible account or you want to support us in another way, you can check out our Patreon.
所以那是 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。而且我在那里发布剧集。所以他们给你，你知道，任何赞助人都有高质量的 RSS 订阅源。所以如果你在 Patreon 上订阅了我们，你知道，不要使用 programthrowdown.com 上的 RSS 订阅源，你可以使用，但 Patreon 上的那个，是，呃，是超级超级高带宽，它是为赞助人准备的，旨在让你尽可能快地获得剧集。所以，呃，所以去看看吧。好吧，是时候介绍我们的节目工具了。节目工具。
So that's patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown. And I post the episodes there. So they give you, you know, any patron has a high quality RSS feed. So if you are subscribed to us on Patreon, you know, don't use the rss feed on programthrowdown.com you can but the the one from patreon is is uh is super super high bandwidth it's meant for patrons meant to get you the episode like as fast as possible and so uh so check that out all right time for our tools of the show. Tool of the show.
我的节目工具是 PyTorch。所以如果你听说过 Torch，Torch 是一个用 Lua 编写的库，它基本上给了你很多张量类型的操作。所以，例如，如果你想乘以矩阵，将矩阵相加，创建一个用于进行某种 AI 项目的神经网络，
My tool of the show is PyTorch. So if you've ever heard of Torch, Torch was a library written in Lua, and it basically gave you a lot of tensor-type operations. So, for example, if you want to multiply matrices, add matrices to each other, create like a neural network for doing some kind of AI project,
你可以使用 Torch。关于 Torch 的事情是它是用 Lua 编写的，所以很难真正让它与其他库很好地配合。所以例如，如果你想从 H5 读取一些数据并将其放入你的 Torch 模型中，如果你想从 H5 读取一些数据并将其放入你的 Torch 模型中，你必须指望 Lua 有一个 H5 或 HD5 读取器。而 Lua 只是没有那么多的支持
you could use Torch. The thing about Torch was it was written in Lua, so it was hard to really make it play nice with other libraries. So for example, if you wanted to read some data from H5 and put that into your Torch model, if you wanted to read some data from H5 and put that into your Torch model, you'd have to count on Lua having an H5 or HD5 reader. And Lua just doesn't have as much support
像其他语言那样。所以他们继续，基本上把所有的 Torch 移植到了 Python。所以 PyTorch 正如它听起来的那样。它真的，真的非常棒。我最近一直在使用它。在过去，我使用过其他类似的库。所以我使用过 Keras，我使用过 TensorFlow，
as other languages. So they went ahead and basically ported all of Torch to Python. And so PyTorch is exactly what it sounds like. It's really, really sharp. I've been using it quite a lot lately. And in the past, I've used other similar libraries. So I've used Keras, I've used TensorFlow,
我使用过 Theano。我几乎使用过所有这些。而且我认为 PyTorch 是目前为止最好的。而且它实际上某种程度上正在接管。你只是看到越来越多的项目是用 PyTorch 完成的。而且它确实是一个非凡的库。设计也是。基本上，所有这些库或编程语言，真的任何东西，它们都有事后诸葛亮的好处。
I've used Theano. I've used pretty much all of these. And I think PyTorch is by far the best. And it's actually sort of taking over. You're just seeing more and more projects being done in PyTorch. And it's really a phenomenal library. The design also. Basically, all of these libraries or programming languages, really anything, they have the benefit of hindsight.
对吧。所以，你知道，在 PyTorch 的情况下，他们真的只是看了所有这些其他库，并说，你知道，我们可以做些什么不同的事情？而且他们做出了一些非常，非常好的设计决策。所以如果你想做一个酷的 AI 项目，或者如果你甚至需要做任何类型的数学密集型项目，看看 PyTorch。它真的很好。我的意思是 NumPy 很好。PyTorch 和 NumPy 之间的最大区别在于 PyTorch 可以在 GPU 上运行。有很多，有很多区别，但那是某种程度上的大区别。我，有人说，嘿，我想做一个有很多繁重数学运算的数学类项目，而且我需要它运行得非常快，
Right. So, you know, in the case of PyTorch, they really just looked at all these other libraries and said, you know, what can we do differently? And they've made some really, really good design decisions. So if you want to do some cool AI project or if you even need to do anything any type of sort of math heavy project check out PyTorch. It's really nice. I mean NumPy is good. The big difference between PyTorch and NumPy is that PyTorch can run on the GPU. There's a lot of a lot of differences but that's sort of the big one. I somebody said, hey, I want to do some math-like project that has a lot of heavy math in it, and I need it to run really fast,
那么你可以在 GPU 上的 PyTorch 上做。它会尖叫。我的也是非常有教育意义且对工作有用。我的是一个游戏，不错，呃，叫，那可能不好笑，因为我想我每一集都做，Suzy Cube。这是，我这次做了家庭作业，它在 iOS 和 Android 上都可用，不错。这是一个平台游戏，风格上，对我来说，它最像《超级马里奥 3D 世界》，那是我和我的孩子们一起玩的 Wii U 游戏，我们很喜欢。它非常符合那种风格。你是一个在 3D 世界中移动的立方体角色。
then you could do it on PyTorch on the GPU. It'll just scream. Mine is also very educational and useful for work mine is a game nice uh called that's not probably funny because i think i do every episode uh suzy cube uh this is i i did my homework this time it is available on both ios and android nice um and this is a platformer in the style of, for me, it's most like Super Mario Land 3D, which is a Wii U game that I play with my kids that we like. It's very much in that style. And you're a cube character moving around in a 3D world.
但大多数平台游戏或那种类型的游戏，我在平板电脑或手机上都很吃力，但控制做得非常好，而且游戏是一种很好的平衡，感觉你正在取得进步，而不是仅仅像巡航一样，这超级容易，完全没问题。而且我相信它是三或四美元，我想可能是，我想是四美元，但所以它不是超级贵，而且这是一个美好的时光。我还没有通关，我只玩了四或五关，但我很喜欢它。它有，你知道，常见的比喻，我想，你可以通过关卡，这本身就是一种壮举，但还有隐藏的星星，其中一些比其他的更隐蔽。
But most platformers or games of that type i struggle with on on tablets or phones um but the controls are done really well and the game is a sort of good balance of feeling like you're making progress without just being like cruising through this is super easy no problem whatsoever um and i believe it's three or four dollars i think probably i think it was four dollars um but so it's not super expensive and it was a good time I've not beaten it yet I've only I'm only about four or five levels in but I'm enjoying it it has the you know common trope I guess of you can get through the level which is a sort of feat of its own but then there's also hidden stars some of which are more hidden than others.
而且每一关都有三颗星星。我正在尝试找到那些作为额外的挑战。不错。那超级有趣。是的，我喜欢做那种游戏，因为那样的话，就像你在玩所有这些益智游戏时真的有两个目标。第一个目标，我的意思是，假设它有一个好的故事，是真正喜欢体验那个完整的故事。第二个目标是解决，显然是解决谜题。
And there's three stars on each level. And I'm trying to find those as an additional challenge. Nice. That's super fun. Yeah, I love games that do that because that way, it's like you have really two goals when you're playing all these puzzle games. The first goal, I mean, assuming it has a good story, is to really like experience that whole story. And the second goal is to solve, obviously solve the puzzles.
所以通过拥有这些某种可选的挑战，它让你某种程度上根据你的技能、运气之类的东西来调整自己的节奏。是的，所以去看看吧。酷。好吧，进入并发话题，或者正如我们在节目开始前一直说的，加密货币。并发，加密货币，是的，加密货币，我想那里有一个加密货币硬币，是的，我们应该，我们应该开始这个。我的意思是，它不可能比狗狗币赚得更少。我的意思是，狗狗币不是最差的，伙计。
And so by having these sort of optional challenges, it lets you sort of pace yourself based on your skill, luck, and stuff like that. Yeah, so check it out. Cool. All right, on to the topic concurrency um or as we kept saying before the show cryptocurrency con cryptocurrency yeah cryptocurrency i think there's a crypto coin in there yeah we should we should start this i mean there's no way it could make less money than Dogecoin. I mean, Dogecoin is not the worst, dude.
我们可以命名比那更差的。哦，是的，那是真的。那是真的。是的，那是……抱歉，我想我本来想说的是它必须更好。一个狗狗币就是一个狗狗币。一个狗狗币就是一个狗狗币。好吧，所以并发。所以，是的，我的意思是……
We can name a lot worse than that. Oh, yeah, that's true. That's true. Yeah, that's... Sorry, I guess what I meant to say is it's got to be better. One Doge is one Doge. One Doge is one Doge. All right, so concurrency. So, yeah, I mean...
那个死了。你为什么要搞并发？是的，Patrick，我们为什么要费心搞并发？为什么不呢？并发是一种方式，大多数人都知道，嗯，我猜有几种方式，但主要的一种是人们知道现代计算机甚至手机中有不止一个核心。几乎所有东西似乎都有不止一个核心。我想即使是最新的 Arduino 也有多个核心。
That died. Why would you do concurrency? Yeah, Patrick, why would we bother with concurrency? Why not? Concurrency is a way to, most people know that, well, I guess there are a couple ways, but the main one is people know that there's more than one core in modern day computers and even phones. Almost everything seems to have more than one core. I think even the newest Arduinos have multiple cores.
也许不是 Arduino。是的，可能即使是 Arduino。树莓派绝对有。哦，是的。好的。所以如果你想利用不止一个这些，你需要一次做不止一件事。你需要采取并发工作，而我们做的正常编程，呃，当你考虑某种编写 C++ 或 Java，嗯，JavaScript，我猜它将不得不考虑具体的应用，但
Maybe not Arduino. Yeah, probably even Arduino. Definitely the Raspberry Pi does. Oh, yeah. Okay. And so if you want to leverage more than one of these, you need to do more than one thing at a time. You need to take concurrent work and the normal programming we do uh when you think about sort of writing c++ or java um javascript i guess it will have to think about exact application but
也许不是Arduino。是的，可能连Arduino也行。树莓派肯定可以。哦，是的。好的。所以如果你想利用其中不止一个功能，你需要同时做不止一件事。你需要处理并发工作，而我们平时进行的常规编程，当你考虑编写C++、Java或者我想是JavaScript时，就必须考虑具体的应用，但
if you're writing an application level programming language go um you know what, when you're doing that, you're writing a set of instructions you expect to execute sequentially. And the processor may do what's called reordering, but you expect it to roughly execute in order. And there's a lot of things that have these dependencies. First do this, then do that. Yeah, basically, it's a guarantee, right? So if you say like x plus 2 and x times 10 and if those are swapped you're kind of in big trouble that's true but there are certain things you can run in parallel or swap and not get into trouble like x equals two and a equals five right right right yeah but it's done behind the. Yeah. But we're 10 that doesn't exist for now. And so concurrency is a way to be able to do, you know, like that example,
如果你在编写应用级编程语言，嗯，你知道吗，当你这样做时，你是在编写一组你期望按顺序执行的指令。处理器可能会进行所谓的重排序，但你期望它大致按顺序执行。有很多东西都有这种依赖关系。先做这个，再做那个。是的，基本上，这是一个保证，对吧？所以如果你说 x 加 2 和 x 乘以 10，如果它们被交换了，你就有大麻烦了，这是真的，但有些事情你可以并行运行或交换而不会遇到麻烦，比如 x 等于 2 和 a 等于 5，对吧，对，对，是的，但这是在后台完成的。是的。但我们假设它现在不存在。所以并发是一种能够做到，你知道，就像那个例子，
X equals two and A equals five. If you want to run those at the same time, you would get done faster, however long it takes to do that assignment. Instead of having to take time to do it twice, you would get it in wall clock time, time to execute it just once because they would happen on two different processors that are independent and can both take care of it yeah um just to explain like so so there's cpu time which is basically like how many clocks does it take to do something and then there's wall time which is how much total time so if you have 100 things you need to do the number of the amount of cpu time is probably fixed let's say right but but if you could do 50 of them on one core and 50 on the other you could half your wall time
X 等于 2，A 等于 5。如果你想同时运行它们，你会更快完成，无论执行该赋值需要多长时间。你不需要花时间做两次，你会在挂钟时间（wall clock time）内完成，即只执行一次的时间，因为它们会在两个独立的处理器上发生，并且都可以处理它。是的，嗯，解释一下，所以有 CPU 时间，基本上就是做某事需要多少时钟周期，然后有挂钟时间，也就是总共花费的时间。所以如果你有 100 件事要做，CPU 时间的总量可能是固定的，假设是这样，对吧？但如果你能在其中一个核心上做 50 件，在另一个核心上做 50 件，你就可以将挂钟时间减半。
even though your cpu time hasn't changed yeah and this is the so when you talk about concurrence you're talking about trying to get some amounts of this i guess you'd say parallelism and there's a lot of things that talk about it and formalisms. And even when I was studying up for this a little bit, remembering from college, these Petri nets and ways of describing parallel accesses. And then I guess the analogy I always hear is that there's different kinds of tasks which are more or less suited to concurrency. And the example is that if you have nine ladies, you can't have a baby in one month, but you could have nine babies in nine months.
即使你的 CPU 时间没有改变。是的，这就是，所以当你谈论并发时，你是在谈论试图获得一定数量的，我想你会说并行性。有很多关于它的讨论和形式主义。即使我在为这个做一点研究时，从大学里回忆起这些 Petri 网和描述并行访问的方法。然后我想我总是听到的类比是，有不同种类的任务，它们或多或少适合并发。例子是，如果你有九个女人，你不能在一个月内生一个孩子，但你可以在九个月内生九个孩子。
Right. So if you have one, well, if they can only have one at a time, I guess this is an oversimplification and a slightly awkward example, but it's one that was always taught to me. Octomom proves you wrong. Yeah, okay. This is a bad example. Well, it's the same, was always taught to me. Octomom proves you wrong. Yeah, okay.
对。所以如果你有一个，嗯，如果她们一次只能生一个，我想这是一个过度简化，是一个稍微尴尬的例子，但这是我一直被教导的。八胞胎母亲证明你是错的。是的，好吧。这是一个糟糕的例子。好吧，是一样的，一直被教导给我。八胞胎母亲证明你是错的。是的，好吧。
This is a bad example. Well, it's the same, but take twins out of it or multiples out of it. Yeah, and what you're trying to say there is that some tasks you really do, as Jason was saying, first I need to take X and add two, and then I need to multiply by 10.
这是一个糟糕的例子。好吧，是一样的，但把双胞胎或多胞胎排除在外。是的，你想表达的是，有些任务你确实需要，正如 Jason 所说，首先我需要取 X 并加 2，然后我需要乘以 10。
And if you do those differently, then you're gonna have an issue. And so splitting that task, as simple as it sounds onto two processors isn't going to go faster. Because one of them is just going to be stuck with nothing to do. So some tasks have these large sequential dependencies. And because of that, it just takes a while to do that. And adding more processors, you could duplicate that work, you could do more of it. But you so if you had to do some image processing one way to get
如果你以不同的方式做这些，那么你就会遇到问题。所以把那个任务拆分，听起来很简单，放到两个处理器上并不会变快。因为其中一个只会无事可做。所以有些任务有这些大的顺序依赖。正因为如此，做这件事需要一段时间。而增加更多的处理器，你可以复制那项工作，你可以做更多。所以如果你必须以某种方式进行图像处理，获得
parallelism is to take a whole image and do it on processor one and a whole image and do it on processor two but depending on the task you're doing it may be possible to do like the top half on processor one and the bottom half on processor two and the two different scenarios are that if you're going to do both images all the way to the end the total time taken wall clock and cpu time is the same but if you're only going to do one image in in splitting the image in half the first image comes out sooner wall clock time than if you have one processor doing image a and one processor doing image b and that's an advantage often because often we worry about how long until we get the first answers out or the soonest answers out think about things like video games
并行性的一种方法是取一整张图像并在处理器 1 上处理，取另一整张图像并在处理器 2 上处理。但根据你正在做的任务，可能可以在处理器 1 上做上半部分，在处理器 2 上做下半部分。这两种不同的场景是，如果你打算把两张图像都处理到底，总的挂钟时间和 CPU 时间是一样的。但如果你只打算处理一张图像，将图像分成两半，第一张图像出来的挂钟时间比你有一个处理器处理图像 A，另一个处理器处理图像 B 要早。这通常是一个优势，因为我们经常担心多久才能得到第一个答案或最早的答案，想想电子游戏之类的东西。
and video games you know you need to get the whole frame rendered in a certain time so doing a lot of the different tasks in parallel helps you get that frame out sooner um versus a pixar movie where you could spend a lot of time just working on a single frame and a whole different set of computers be working on a different frame than what you were on. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Another reason why you want concurrency is if you have a lot of asynchronous calls that you have to make. So for example, let's say you have a web server and somebody goes and hits your web server. You want to hit a database, get some information from that database, and then send that information back to that person and wait for that person to get it. Right. So you're doing a lot of waiting. You're waiting for the database, you're waiting for the person
在电子游戏中，你知道你需要在一个特定的时间内渲染出整个帧，所以并行执行许多不同的任务有助于你更快地输出该帧。嗯，相比之下，皮克斯电影，你可以花很多时间只处理一个帧，而另一组计算机可以在处理与你不同的帧。是的，是的，完全正确。你想要并发的另一个原因是如果你有很多必须进行的异步调用。例如，假设你有一个 Web 服务器，有人访问你的 Web 服务器。你想访问数据库，从该数据库获取一些信息，然后将该信息发回给那个人，并等待那个人收到它。对。所以你做了很多等待。你在等数据库，你在等那个人
to get your reply, right? Sometimes you have to resend the reply if they didn't get it, things like that. And I mean, imagine if the web server just ran in one thread. So like, while it's doing all this waiting, nobody else could get on your website. That'd be terrible. I mean, most requests, I think, I mean, it depends on a lot of factors. Let's say they take a second. So that would mean you can only have one person per second on your website. Um, you know, so, so another thing to do there is, is, is use concurrency to say, okay, it doesn't even necessarily have to be, um, have to use multiple cores, it could just use one core, but it could just release, you know, some type of lock or something. So it could say, okay, I'm going to go to the database and ask it for some information. And until I get that information back, you know, I'm just going to chill and someone else could do something on the core. And so
收到你的回复，对吧？有时如果他们没收到，你还得重新发送回复，诸如此类。我的意思是，想象一下如果 Web 服务器只在一个线程中运行。所以，当它在做所有这些等待时，其他人就无法访问你的网站。那太糟糕了。我的意思是，大多数请求，我想，我的意思是，这取决于很多因素。假设它们需要一秒钟。那意味着你的网站每秒只能有一个人访问。嗯，你知道，所以，所以另一件要做的事情是，使用并发来说，好的，它甚至不一定非要，嗯，非要使用多个核心，它只需要使用一个核心，但它可以释放，你知道，某种锁之类的东西。所以它可以说，好的，我要去数据库问它要一些信息。而在我得到那个信息之前，你知道，我只是会休息一下，其他人可以在核心上做点别的事情。所以
that's how most web servers work is they just are this whole waterfall of asynchronous calls. And the entire time one of those calls is in progress, that, I guess we'll call it thread to same time, uh, on one core even. And, um, uh, you just taking advantage of the fact that you're spending a lot of time waiting. So, so yeah, that's the other sort of big use case between the two of those you've covered, you know, 90% of the, um, you know, uses for a concurrency. Yeah. And I think it is useful because people talked a lot about having multiple, uh, processes or like if you ever did UI work or still do not doing something on the main thread. And people sort of make this comment. But the idea is sort of what Jason is pointing out, which is even if you only have one processor, you do this time slicing, you could have prioritizations.
这就是大多数 Web 服务器的工作方式，它们只是这一整串异步调用。在其中一个调用进行期间的整个时间，那个，我想我们称之为线程，在同一个时间，呃，甚至在一个核心上。而且，嗯，呃，你只是利用了你花了很多时间在等待这一事实。所以，所以是的，这是另一个大用例，在这两者之间，你已经涵盖了，你知道，90% 的，嗯，你知道，并发的用途。是的，而且我认为这很有用，因为人们谈论了很多关于拥有多个，呃，进程，或者如果你曾经做过 UI 工作或者现在还在做，不在主线程上做某事。人们会发表这样的评论。但这个想法有点像 Jason 指出的，即使你只有一个处理器，你做这种时间片轮转，你可以有优先级排序。
But the idea is you want certain things to be very responsive. And if you need to do a long running task, even if it's not going off to another computer, you want to make sure that that task that's long running has lower priority and gets interrupted to service things which you want a quick response to. So if you imagine like this, not exactly how web servers work, but you know, hey, Jason, I have a question for you. And he says, okay, what's your question? I give him a complex differential equation he needs to go solve. You may want him to say,
但这个想法是你希望某些事情非常响应。如果你需要做一个长时间运行的任务，即使它不是去另一台计算机，你也希望确保那个长时间运行的任务具有较低的优先级，并被中断以服务于你想要快速响应的事情。所以如果你想象一下，虽然 Web 服务器的工作方式不完全是这样，但你知道，嘿，Jason，我有一个问题要问你。他说，好的，你的问题是什么？我给他一个他需要去解决的复杂微分方程。你可能希望他说，
okay, I'm working on it, and then go work on solving it. But getting a, I'm working on it, so I know he's not dead or not responding to me is a useful thing, to have that initial very quick response. And concurrency, even if you only have a single processor, allows you to sort of keep things working well. Yeah, exactly.
好的，我正在处理它，然后去解决它。但是得到一个“我正在处理它”，这样我就知道他没有死或者没有不响应我，这是一个有用的事情，得到那个最初的非常快速的响应。而并发，即使你只有一个处理器，也允许你让事情保持良好运行。是的，完全正确。
And so basically the core like mechanisms by which you get concurrency, one is through message passing. So imagine you have sort of two threads and they're both running, or let's say even two processes. So the difference between a thread and a process is multiple threads share the same memory, but multiple processes, at least by default,
所以基本上，你获得并发的核心机制，一个是通过消息传递。所以想象你有两个线程，它们都在运行，或者我们甚至说两个进程。所以线程和进程之间的区别是多个线程共享相同的内存，但多个进程，至少默认情况下，
they don't share the same memory. So you couldn't create an object in one process and just pass the pointer to another process and use the same memory. So you couldn't create an object in one process and just pass the pointer to another process and use the same object. It won't work. So for example, if you have two processes and you want them to, as I said, pass some object around, one process has to serialize it. So turn it into just a series of ones and zeros, like a string or something like that, and then send it to the other process, right? And you can do the same with threads as well, right? Just you don't have to, but you can. And we call that message passing, right? And it's just the same as if you were to send a message to another machine on the internet or something like that. You basically are just going to package up that message, send it across, and the other person's going to unpackage it.
它们不共享相同的内存。所以你不能在一个进程中创建一个对象，然后直接把指针传给另一个进程并使用相同的内存。所以你不能在一个进程中创建一个对象，然后直接把指针传给另一个进程并使用相同的对象。这行不通。所以例如，如果你有两个进程，你想让它们，正如我所说，传递一些对象，一个进程必须序列化它。所以把它变成一系列的 1 和 0，比如字符串之类的东西，然后发送给另一个进程，对吧？你也可以对线程做同样的事情，对吧？只是你不必这样做，但你可以。我们称之为消息传递，对吧？这和你向互联网上的另一台机器发送消息之类的东西是一样的。你基本上只是要把那个消息打包，发送过去，然后对方会解包它。
So if you hear things like IPC, inter-process communication, that's going to be a way to pass messages. And in fact, at least on Unix, IPC and TCP work almost the same way. You can actually open a socket to another process on your machine, or you can open a socket to, you know, yahoo.com or something like that. And it's almost the same code, right?
所以如果你听到像 IPC，进程间通信这样的词，那将是一种传递消息的方法。事实上，至少在 Unix 上，IPC 和 TCP 的工作方式几乎一样。你实际上可以在你的机器上打开一个套接字到另一个进程，或者你可以打开一个套接字到，你知道，yahoo.com 之类的东西。而且代码几乎是一样的，对吧？
So it's really kind of, you know, it's meant to work that way, right? Another way to do it is through shared memory. And so, you know, this gets a little bit complicated because it's very OS specific. Like on some, especially older OSs, you actually have to use files and file locking and things like that. But at a high level, just imagine there's a chunk of memory that both processes can access, right? So actually, I mean, if you're talking about threads, then everything is shared memory, right?
所以它确实是，你知道，它就是为了那样工作，对吧？另一种方法是通过共享内存。所以，你知道，这变得有点复杂，因为它非常依赖于操作系统。比如在一些，特别是较旧的操作系统上，你实际上必须使用文件和文件锁定之类的东西。但在高层面上，只要想象有一块内存是两个进程都可以访问的，对吧？所以实际上，我的意思是，如果你在谈论线程，那么一切都是共享内存，对吧？
So then it's just a matter of saying, okay, this object, I'm gonna access this object from multiple threads and just sort of effectively writing some documentation and things like that so that people know that, hey, while they're editing this object or reading this object or something like that so that people know that hey while they're um you know editing this object or reading this object like that it's possible another thread is is also doing that at the same time yeah so i mean i i think for this threads um especially in the last few years this has gotten in um i guess application programs much easier. So in Python, there's threading.
所以这只是一个说，好的，这个对象，我将从多个线程访问这个对象，并只是有效地编写一些文档之类的东西，以便人们知道，嘿，当他们正在编辑这个对象或读取这个对象时，或者诸如此类，以便人们知道嘿，当他们，嗯，你知道，正在编辑这个对象或读取这个对象时，像那样，另一个线程也可能同时在做这件事。是的，所以我认为对于这些线程，嗯，特别是在过去几年里，这在，嗯，我想应用编程中变得容易多了。所以在 Python 中，有线程。
In Java, there's now, there's always been threading, but there's easy ways to even just sort of multiprocess streams where this shared memory kind of happens without even thinking about it. And even in C++, there's standard thread now and standard async, which standard async is still a little broken, but... Oh, wait, really? Tell me more. Well, no, I forget the exact nuances. thread now and standard async which standard async is still a little broken but oh wait really
在 Java 中，现在有，一直都有线程，但甚至有简单的方法来进行多进程流，这种共享内存甚至不需要思考就会发生。即使在 C++ 中，现在也有标准线程和标准异步，虽然标准异步仍然有点损坏，但是…… 哦，等等，真的吗？多告诉我一些。好吧，不，我忘记了确切的细微差别。线程现在和标准异步，虽然标准异步仍然有点损坏，但是哦，等等，真的吗？
standard tell me more well no i i forget the exact nuances and and i think like i do a lot of my work in c++ 11 and 14 and it was broken and i don't know if they fixed it in 17 um async has a weird dispatch policy is the is this long and short of it you have to take special care to make sure you're like when you run a standard async command it happens right then like the function will run in parallel when you think it does as opposed to sort of getting deferred uh if i've already called the argument correctly um but yeah so i mean as jason pointed out the for sort of threads it's just implicit what you might even like i was mentioning you might just sort of write an anonymous function,
标准，多告诉我一些。好吧，不，我忘记了确切的细微差别，而且我认为，比如我在 C++ 11 和 14 中做了很多工作，它是损坏的，我不知道他们在 17 中是否修复了它。嗯，异步有一个奇怪的调度策略，这就是长话短说。你必须特别小心，确保当你运行一个标准异步命令时，它就在那时发生，就像函数会在你认为它会的时候并行运行，而不是被推迟。如果我已经正确调用了参数，嗯，但是的，所以我的意思是，正如 Jason 指出的，对于线程来说，这只是隐含的，你甚至可能像我提到的那样，你可能只是写一个匿名函数，
a Lambda function, or have a function call just in line with something. You say, hey, I want to go do this 10 times, or I want to go do this across these slices of the data. And that's just an object that you're sharing out to those threads. It doesn't have to be copied. It just gets accessed in place.
一个 Lambda 函数，或者让一个函数调用与某事内联。你说，嘿，我想去把这个做 10 次，或者我想去在这些数据切片中做这个。那只是一个你共享给那些线程的对象。它不需要被复制。它只是在原地被访问。
Yep, that totally makes sense. One, one last thing about this is, uh, there are like thread pools and, and, and process pools. And so the idea there is, you're creating a thread is actually, especially creating a process is pretty expensive. I mean, you know, the computers nowadays are so fast that you really don't notice, right? I mean, unless you're doing a lot of it. But under the hood, there's actually pretty significant overhead around creating those things. And so there's this concept of a pool where basically, you know, at the start of your application, you say, OK, I know I have a ton of work to do. And I know I have, let's say, eight cores. So I'm going to create eight threads right at the beginning. And these eight threads are just going to start taking work.
是的，这完全说得通。关于这个的最后一件事是，嗯，有线程池和进程池。所以这个想法是，创建一个线程实际上，特别是创建一个进程是相当昂贵的。我的意思是，你知道，现在的计算机速度非常快，你真的不会注意到，对吧？我的意思是，除非你做了很多。但在底层，创建这些东西实际上有相当大的开销。所以有一个池的概念，基本上，你知道，在你的应用程序开始时，你说，好的，我知道我有很多工作要做。而且我知道我有，假设，八个核心。所以我将在开始时创建八个线程。而这八个线程将开始接受工作。
So as soon as I have some work, I'm going to say, hey, eight threads, go and take this work. And I don't really, you know, there's a lot of complexity around, okay, which thread is free, who can accept the work, et cetera, et cetera. So the thread pool kind of abstracts all of that away. So you basically, and almost every language has this, you basically say, you know, I want a thread pool with eight threads. And then you can just say pool dot, you know, it depends on the language, pool dot nq or
所以一旦我有了一些工作，我会说，嘿，八个线程，去接受这个工作。而且我真的，你知道，围绕着哪个线程是空闲的，谁可以接受工作等等，有很多复杂性。所以线程池抽象了所有这些。所以你基本上，而且几乎每种语言都有这个，你基本上说，你知道，我想要一个有八个线程的线程池。然后你就可以说池点，你知道，这取决于语言，池点入队（nq）或者
pool dot start or something like that. And you could give it a function, and it will handle, if you call it nine times in a row really quickly, it'll take that ninth one and it'll wait for one of the first eight to finish. It'll kind of handle all of that for you. So the thing to point out is if you use message passing, whether you're talking to something on the same computer or two different computers, as Jason was pointing out with this sort of socket example, is actually not immediately obvious to you or really doesn't make much of a difference as far as you writing the program is concerned. But if you're doing shared memory, there's extra steps that need to be taken. Or even if you're using processes,
池点开始（start）之类的。你可以给它一个函数，它会处理，如果你连续九次非常快地调用它，它会取第九个，并等待前八个中的一个完成。它会为你处理所有这些。所以要指出的是，如果你使用消息传递，无论你是与同一台计算机上的东西交谈还是与两台不同的计算机交谈，正如 Jason 用这种套接字示例指出的那样，实际上对你来说并不显而易见，或者就你编写程序而言，并没有太大的区别。但如果你在做共享内存，则需要采取额外的步骤。或者即使你正在使用进程，
sometimes you need to use a resource. Like I need to talk to, oh, that's a bad example, like the hard drive, let's say, and I'm going to be writing stuff out in the hard, oh, the speaker. I want to go talk to the speaker. And if two programs are talking to the speaker,
有时你需要使用资源。比如我需要和，哦，这是一个糟糕的例子，比如硬盘，假设，我要把东西写到硬盘上，哦，扬声器。我想去和扬声器交谈。如果两个程序都在和扬声器交谈，
it would just be nonsense. So in our system, we don't want, you know, the speaker to be accessed by multiple programs. So there's this concept of, you know, locking that resource so that I'm the only one who writes to it. So that garbage audio doesn't come out. And so in order to do that, these locking concepts need to be done typically by the operating system and exposed in the programming language in some way but they allow you to sort of do coordination and the things you would hear are semaphores mutexes locks and they come in a variety of forms but roughly they're all around this making sure that you don't collide in how you're trying to change or use something and what that amounts to is mutexes are mutually exclusive which says there's some bit of
那简直就是胡说八道。所以在我们的系统中，我们不希望，你知道，扬声器被多个程序访问。所以有一个概念，你知道，锁定那个资源，这样我是唯一一个写入它的人。这样就不会发出垃圾音频。为了做到这一点，这些锁定概念通常需要由操作系统完成，并以某种方式在编程语言中公开，但它们允许你进行协调，你会听到的东西是信号量、互斥锁、锁，它们有多种形式，但大致上它们都是围绕着确保你在试图改变或使用某物时不会发生冲突，而这相当于互斥锁是互斥的，它说有一点
code and i want to guarantee that when i run this bit of code i'm the only person with regards to some you know some signal and is, if there's two threads running the exact same function, it's probably the same block of code, you only want to be executed one at a time. But it could be two different things you want mutexes in order to protect maybe, like I said, the speaker. And so you want to say, hey, I have a mutex. Anytime someone's going to use the speaker, then they're going to acquire the mutex. And you know that when you acquire the mutex, that you're the only one who will be talking to the speaker at that time, because everybody else is mutually excluded. And then you get into a conversation about, instead of just doing this with a variable, where you could end up with a race condition but
代码，我想保证当我运行这段代码时，我是唯一一个关于某种，你知道，某种信号的人。如果有两个线程运行完全相同的函数，它可能是相同的代码块，你只希望一次执行一个。但它可能是两个不同的东西，你需要互斥锁来保护，也许，就像我说的，扬声器。所以你想说，嘿，我有一个互斥锁。任何时候有人要使用扬声器，他们就会获取互斥锁。而且你知道当你获取互斥锁时，你是当时唯一一个会和扬声器交谈的人，因为其他人都被互斥了。然后你进入一个对话，而不是只用一个变量做这件事，你可能会以竞争条件结束，但
even if you avoid it the nice thing about mutex is they often have the built-in concept that instead of pulling where the processor is busy in a very tight loop just going are you free are you free are you free are you free are you free there's normally more sophisticated mechanisms where you'll be able to put the other threads into a state where the processor is free to do other work, put them effectively to sleep and have them get woken up when the mutex is free for them to acquire. And that has the advantage of allowing, again, the computer to process more stuff. So as Jason's example, when something goes off to use the database, you don't want to just sit there saying, is the database transaction done?
即使你避免了它，互斥锁的好处是它们通常有一个内置的概念，即不是轮询，处理器在一个非常紧密的循环中忙碌，只是问你空闲吗？你空闲吗？你空闲吗？你空闲吗？你空闲吗？通常有更复杂的机制，你将能够把其他线程置于一个状态，处理器可以自由地做其他工作，有效地让它们进入睡眠状态，并在互斥锁空闲供它们获取时唤醒它们。这有一个优势，再次允许计算机处理更多东西。所以正如 Jason 的例子，当某事去使用数据库时，你不想只是坐在那里说，数据库事务完成了吗？
Is it done? Is it done? You want to sort of be notified, okay, hey, I'm done now, and receive that signal. So you're not locking up all the computer processor just asking, are you done? Yep. Yeah. And so the mutex implementation, even on every language, it comes with a lock object. And so what the lock object does is you say, hey, you know, lock this mutex. And what that will do is it will lock it. And, you know, any point from that lock call onwards, you know, you have total ownership. You know no one else is in that code. Or if someone else has the lock, it'll just wait. So, you know, a common problem with multi-threading is that you could end up saying, okay, I want to lock this object
完成了吗？完成了吗？你想要某种被通知，好的，嘿，我现在完成了，并接收那个信号。所以你不会锁定所有的计算机处理器只是问，你完成了吗？是的。是的。所以互斥锁实现，即使在每种语言中，它都带有一个锁对象。所以锁对象所做的是你说，嘿，你知道，锁定这个互斥锁。它会做的是它会锁定它。而且，你知道，从那个锁调用开始的任何点，你知道，你拥有完全的所有权。你知道没有其他人在这段代码中。或者如果其他人有锁，它就会等待。所以，你知道，多线程的一个常见问题是，你最终可能会说，好的，我想锁定这个对象
because, you know, I want to increment it. And you have another object you want to lock, and you want to, let's say, print that you incremented it. And if you have different threads sort of locking different objects, you can end up causing the system to be really, really slow and not realize it. Because you're tracing through your code, and you're saying, oh, this function's pretty quick, this function's quick. It's very hard to know how long a lock will take, because you kind
因为，你知道，我想增加它。而且你有另一个你想锁定的对象，你想，假设，打印你增加了它。如果你有不同的线程锁定不同的对象，你最终可能会导致系统变得非常非常慢，而没有意识到这一点。因为你在追踪你的代码，你说，哦，这个函数很快，这个函数很快。很难知道锁需要多长时间，因为你有点
of have to think about what else is going on in the system. Yeah, that's right. And this is sort of these shared memory versus message passing, and there's a variety of other things are, I guess, a formal way of describing it. But what I often find in practice is that you see somewhat of a kind of hybrid solution. So what I've seen kind of the most for when someone actually has to go handle raw concurrency themselves is in a language like C++ or Java, you end up spinning up some threads to do something, and you have a queue that describes you know sort of each of the things you want done and you put a lock on that queue and so you effectively get a kind of low cost lightweight um message passing interface where i have a job queue
必须考虑系统中还有什么在发生。是的，那是对的。这就是这些共享内存与消息传递，还有各种其他东西，我想是一种描述它的正式方式。但我经常在实践中发现的是，你看到了某种混合解决方案。所以我看到最多的，当有人真正必须自己处理原始并发时，是在像 C++ 或 Java 这样的语言中，你最终会启动一些线程来做某事，并且你有一个队列来描述，你知道，你想要完成的每一件事，并且你在那个队列上加了一个锁，所以你有效地获得了一种低成本、轻量级的消息传递接口，我有工作队列
of things i want to go execute it it it might be like parameters or little messages that have come in or pieces of an image. And I sort of add a description of the work to be done to a queue. And then I have however many threads that spin up. And when a thread wakes up, it tries to acquire the lock on the queue. It reads the data out of the queue
我想要去执行的东西，它可能是参数或进来的小消息或图像的片段。我把要完成的工作的描述添加到队列中。然后我有无论多少个线程启动。当一个线程醒来时，它试图获取队列上的锁。它从队列中读取数据
and then releases a lock, does its work. And then there's typically an output queue where when it finishes, it acquires the lock on of the queue and then releases a lock does its work and then there's typically an output queue where when it finishes it it acquires the lock on the output queue puts the data in unlocks it and goes back and tries to get something from the input again and if you just sort of do that you know over and over again you end up with an effectively what looks a lot like message passing but using in that the sort of inputs and outputs are going into a shared structure, but the individual things themselves aren't shared.
然后释放锁，做它的工作。然后通常有一个输出队列，当它完成时，它获取队列上的锁，然后释放锁做它的工作，然后通常有一个输出队列，当它完成时，它获取输出队列上的锁，把数据放进去，解锁它，然后回去试图从输入中再获取一些东西。如果你只是，你知道，一遍又一遍地那样做，你最终会得到一个看起来很像消息传递的东西，但使用输入和输出进入一个共享结构，但单个事物本身并没有被共享。
The individual sort of parcels are, but you might have a read only something that's shared. Like you might only pass the pixel coordinates of the image to process, but the image itself is kept read only. So even though it is shared, you're not really editing it and you don't run into maybe the same complexity you might if everybody was simultaneously editing the image. Yep. Yeah, exactly. So yeah, the two big pitfalls
单个包裹是共享的，但你可能有一个只读的东西被共享。比如你可能只把图像的像素坐标传给进程，但图像本身保持只读。所以即使它是共享的，你也没有真正编辑它，你也不会遇到如果每个人都在同时编辑图像时可能遇到的那种复杂性。是的。是的，完全正确。所以是的，两个大陷阱
are one is race conditions. Do you want to talk about race conditions? I'll take that. Okay, sure. So race conditions is a generic term, but it just means when two things are running in the system, you can get unintended consequences where you think you're, you know, I want to set variable A to two and then B to three. And then something happens where you find out during debug that a was three when b was three instead of a being two and it might be because some other piece of code
一个是竞争条件。你想谈谈竞争条件吗？我来谈这个。好的，当然。所以竞争条件是一个通用术语，但它只是意味着当系统中有两件事在运行时，你可能会得到意想不到的后果，你认为你，你知道，我想把变量 A 设置为 2，然后把 B 设置为 3。然后发生了一些事情，你在调试时发现当 B 为 3 时 A 为 3，而不是 A 为 2，这可能是因为其他代码片段
was setting a to three and then b to something else and you have this race condition where two people are modifying something and you think it should happen in a certain order but because they're sort of not synchronized in some way via one of the locking mechanisms or semaphores we discussed before that you're sort of up to a chance where sometimes it might happen in a way that looks sort of a little bit out of order um so example would be like uh printing to the screen if you have two threads printing to the screen the data can get intermixed and that it's sort of a race condition that you're trying to write out your whole message but while you're trying to write out someone else comes in and writes out too and that might not be a harmful
正在把 A 设置为 3，然后把 B 设置为其他东西，你有这个竞争条件，两个人正在修改某物，你认为它应该按特定顺序发生，但因为它们没有通过我们之前讨论的锁定机制或信号量以某种方式同步，所以你有点碰运气，有时它可能以看起来有点乱序的方式发生。嗯，所以例子就像，呃，打印到屏幕，如果你有两个线程打印到屏幕，数据可能会混在一起，这是一种你试图写出你的完整消息的竞争条件，但在你试图写出时，别人进来了也写出了，那可能不是一个有害的
race condition but sometimes race conditions uh can be harmful where you sort of think almost transactionally like this set of operations going to happen all at once but in reality somebody else could come in in the middle and do something. And that would result in a risk condition. Yeah, exactly. I mean, a simple way to observe this, right, is if you create two threads and those threads just immediately try to print hello and then print world, you'll often get hello, hello, world, world. Right. hello hello world world right and so uh um you know as soon as you start introducing kind of in that case as patrick says just printing so you start introducing logic that becomes really yeah
竞争条件，但有时竞争条件可能是危险的，你认为几乎是事务性的，就像这组操作会一次性发生，但实际上别人可能会在中间进来做点什么。那会导致风险条件。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，观察这一点的一个简单方法，对吧，是如果你创建两个线程，而那些线程只是立即尝试打印 hello 然后打印 world，你通常会得到 hello, hello, world, world。对。hello hello world world 对，所以，嗯，你知道，一旦你开始引入，在这种情况下，正如 Patrick 所说，只是打印，所以你开始引入逻辑，那变得真的，是的
so you think about hello world coming out as sort of one unit of thing but in reality it's actually many many different instructions that have to run yep yeah exactly so what are deadlocks all right deadlocks i'm gonna see if i if i can get this right hang on i hear i hear wikipedia what is no no no no uh you tell me uh check me out okay but i think so so for example let's say um i'm trying to come up with a really solid example. Let's say, for example, you have a thread that is... Let's say you have some type of database, and this database is holding information to email. So it's some kind of reporting database, right?
所以你认为 hello world 出来是某种单位的东西，但实际上它实际上是许多许多必须运行的不同指令。是的，是的，完全正确。那么什么是死锁？好的，死锁，我要看看我是否能弄对，等等，我听到了，我听到了维基百科，什么，不，不，不，不，呃，你告诉我，呃，检查我，好的，但我认为，所以，例如，假设，嗯，我试图想出一个非常扎实的例子。假设，例如，你有一个线程是…… 假设你有一些类型的数据库，而这个数据库持有电子邮件信息。所以它是一种报告数据库，对吧？
And then you have a reporting, so you have a thread for just kind of managing that database. Then you have a reporting service. And this service, you know, takes things from the database and actually sends them out over email, right? And so you have these two threads, and so you have a sort of mutex.
然后你有一个报告，所以你有一个线程只是为了管理那个数据库。然后你有一个报告服务。而这个服务，你知道，从数据库中获取东西，并实际上通过电子邮件发送出去，对吧？所以你有这两个线程，所以你有一种互斥锁。
So when the database is updating the sending the service has to wait and when the service is you know pulling something from the database to send it off the database has to wait to update right and so now someone goes in and introduces let's say multi-part messages so or or some kind of instant message or something like that. So the database is updating. And while the database is updating, the database gets this request that says, OK, send an instant message. I need this to go out immediately. So it waits on the server. It says, hey, service that's sending out these emails, I need this to go out right away.
所以当数据库正在更新时，发送服务必须等待，而当服务正在，你知道，从数据库中拉取东西发送出去时，数据库必须等待更新，对吧？所以现在有人进来并引入了，假设，多部分消息，或者某种即时消息之类的东西。所以数据库正在更新。而在数据库更新时，数据库收到了这个请求，说，好的，发送即时消息。我需要这个立即发出去。所以它在服务器上等待。它说，嘿，正在发送这些电子邮件的服务，我需要这个马上发出去。
But the service that's sending the email, they are in this loop where they are waiting for the database to finish updating. So because remember how they work, right? They wait for an update and then they check it. So they're waiting for the database to update. The database update has this new like emergency mode and it wants to send something and they're both waiting on each other. And that's a deadlock, right? And it's actually extremely easy to do that and it's very painful because what happens is your system just grinds to a halt. And you can usually see this happening
但正在发送电子邮件的服务，它们处于这个循环中，它们正在等待数据库完成更新。所以因为记住它们是如何工作的，对吧？它们等待更新，然后检查它。所以它们在等待数据库更新。数据库更新有这个新的，像紧急模式，它想发送一些东西，它们都在互相等待。这就是死锁，对吧？而且实际上非常容易做到这一点，而且非常痛苦，因为发生的事情是你的系统只是陷入停顿。而且你通常可以看到这种情况发生
because all of your logs will just lock up. Everything will just lock up. But you won't be using any of the processor. It's just kind of sitting there as if it's idle. And so that's a pretty painful situation. We actually had one of those a couple of days ago, and it's not pretty to debug. It's really difficult, actually.
因为你所有的日志都会锁定。一切都会锁定。但你不会使用任何处理器。它只是坐在那里，好像它是空闲的。所以这是一个相当痛苦的情况。我们实际上几天前就有过一个，调试起来并不好看。实际上非常困难。
Yeah, I think it's difficult to explain. But I mean, extracting out the most obvious dangerous conditions is when there's more than a single resource that you need to get your job done. So if a single process needs to use things that are locked by more than a single protection mechanism. So that's, you know know when would you have oh that's you have two systems and i need to lock system a and do something but then i also need to go lock system b and maybe at the start you don't say i just want to lock a and b together because maybe what i'm doing with a takes a really long time and b i only need for a very short amount of time. But then if you have another process which needs B for a long time
是的，我认为这很难解释。但我的意思是，提取出最明显的危险条件是当你需要不止一个资源来完成你的工作时。所以如果一个进程需要使用被不止一个保护机制锁定的东西。所以那是，你知道，什么时候你会，哦，那是，你有两个系统，我需要锁定系统 A 并做某事，但然后我也需要去锁定系统 B，也许在开始时你没有说，我只是想把 A 和 B 锁在一起，因为也许我用 A 做的事情需要很长时间，而 B 我只需要很短的时间。但如果你有另一个进程需要 B 很长时间
and then A for a short time at the end before finishing off a write to B, then what you can end up is, as Jason was trying to describe, is you end up with this deadlock where A gets locked, B gets locked by two different processes, and then they go try to
然后在最后在完成对 B 的写入之前需要 A 很短的时间，那么你最终可能会，正如 Jason 试图描述的那样，你最终会陷入这种死锁，A 被锁定，B 被两个不同的进程锁定，然后它们去试图
lock the other resource, but it's held by someone else, and you're sort of stuck. And this happens, it sounds really like, oh, I'll just never do that. But as Jason was saying, it's actually pretty subtle that you're doing this, because in a really big system, there's often many locks flying around and being locked and unlocked and people are trying to write codes efficient and um for me the thing that that i sort of when when we deal with them at work as often as possible and we'll get to this in a second with advice is try to just use a single lock until you know you don't that that's not working for you and you actually prove that that's inefficient so if you have multiple things that that's not working for you. And you actually prove that that's inefficient.
锁定另一个资源，但它被别人持有了，你有点被卡住了。而且这发生了，听起来真的很像，哦，我永远不会那样做。但正如 Jason 所说，你正在这样做实际上相当微妙，因为在一个非常大的系统中，通常有很多锁在飞来飞去，被锁定和解锁，人们试图编写高效的代码，嗯，对我来说，当我们在工作中处理它们时，尽可能多地，我们稍后会谈到建议，尝试只使用一个锁，直到你知道那对你不奏效，并且你实际上证明了那效率低下。所以如果你有多个东西，那对你不奏效。而且你实际上证明了那效率低下。
So if you have multiple things that need protection against race conditions or need mutexing, try to just lock them all together, even if that's less efficient. And so what that means is, say I need to have resource A, and then there's also a resource B, but I'm not using it. But someone else might want to use B and share it
所以如果你有多个东西需要防止竞争条件或需要互斥，尝试只把它们锁在一起，即使那效率较低。所以这意味着，假设我需要有资源 A，然后还有一个资源 B，但我没有使用它。但其他人可能想使用 B 并共享它
and so you say I'll create a lock for A and a lock for B but then now you have this opportunity where if someone else comes along and needs both A and B they can end up in this race condition state so instead just say lock A and B at the same time like all of the resources which are prone to having this condition all sit under a single lock. Because if there's only one lock in the system, you actually never can have this problem. But that's an oversimplification.
所以你说我会为 A 创建一个锁，为 B 创建一个锁，但现在你有这个机会，如果其他人过来需要 A 和 B，他们最终可能会陷入这种竞争条件状态，所以相反，只要说同时锁定 A 和 B，就像所有容易出现这种情况的资源都坐在一个锁下。因为如果系统中只有一个锁，你实际上永远不会有这个问题。但这是一种过度简化。
It doesn't always work, but it works more often than you think. And a lot of times, if you can do the work needed in the lock very, very quickly, then the amount of contention, the amount of time spent, as Jason was saying, waiting around for the lock to be freed, if it's low enough, then it kind of doesn't matter that there aren't these fine grain locks. Yeah, exactly. I mean, very rarely do you need a lock for a long period of time, especially like if you follow that sort of design pattern that Patrick mentioned earlier, you know, you're only accessing the lock to just send basically signals around. And all of the work is happening outside of the lock. And if you kind of can follow that, then you never need so many locks.
它并不总是有效，但它比你想象的更经常有效。而且很多时候，如果你能非常非常快地完成锁中需要的工作，那么争用量，花费的时间，正如 Jason 所说，等待锁被释放，如果它足够低，那么有没有这些细粒度的锁就无所谓了。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，你很少需要长时间的锁，特别是如果你遵循 Patrick 之前提到的那种设计模式，你知道，你只是为了发送信号而访问锁。所有的工作都在锁之外发生。如果你能遵循那种方式，那么你就永远不需要那么多锁。
You never need that much control. Yeah. Basically, you know, both Patrick and I have done a lot of threading and it's a total it's a total nightmare. It's very hard to debug. So I'll transition into my my first bit of advice, which I just gave one, but I'll give another, which is a lot of times people think, oh, I'm all multi thread this. I guess this is early optimization problem again. But like, I'm going to multi-thread this or I'm going to add concurrency here. And what they're really just getting is complexity. There's a lot of overhead in not just these locks,
你永远不需要那么多控制。是的。基本上，你知道，Patrick 和我都做过很多线程，这完全是一个噩梦。调试起来非常困难。所以我将过渡到我的第一个建议，我刚才给了一个，但我会再给一个，这就是很多时候人们认为，哦，我将多线程处理这个。我想这又是早期优化问题。但就像，我将多线程处理这个，或者我将在这里添加并发。而他们真正得到的是复杂性。不仅这些锁有很大的开销，
but also, as Jason mentioned, spinning up threads, allocating, deallocating things. You tend to end up with more copying of the data because as you're trying to organize it and stuff and so non-obviously sometimes you for instance if you can only split it into sort of two or three threads the startup and organization cost for for having three threads do the work may not be enough to merit having the multi-threading it might be faster just to have the single processor work on it and be faster just to have the single processor
而且，正如 Jason 提到的，启动线程，分配，释放东西。你往往最终会有更多的数据复制，因为当你试图组织它时，等等，所以非显而易见地，有时你，例如，如果你只能把它拆分成两三个线程，启动和组织成本，对于让三个线程做这项工作可能不足以值得拥有多线程，让单个处理器处理它可能更快，让单个处理器处理它可能更快。
work on it and be done with it rather than going through that overhead of trying to split it up into parts and parcel it out to everyone because there's inherently more synchronizing an organization that happen to have has to happen as part of that so one my big cautionary advice is both have measurements in advance that show you need an improvement. And then when you go add or start adding it, add it in as simple a way as you can and show that you're actually getting a speed up. Because it might be that the overhead dominates the cost and the actual computation. Like we mentioned, you know, setting a variable or doing a simple addition. If you're trying to multi-thread just doing an addition,
直接做完它，而不是费力地把它拆分成多个部分并分发给每个人，因为这本质上需要更多的组织协调工作。所以我的一大忠告是：首先要有衡量标准，证明你确实需要改进。然后当你开始添加并发时，尽可能以最简单的方式添加，并证明你确实获得了速度提升。因为开销可能会超过计算本身的成本。就像我们提到的，比如设置一个变量或进行简单的加法运算。如果你试图对一个加法操作进行多线程处理，
that's not going to be ideal because addition runs really fast and so unless you have a ton of additions to do um you know say i only have five but i'll put them in you know five different threads and have it do it the overhead cost is going to dominate there because the amount of work to be done is really small yep yeah exactly um yeah mean the, the biggest piece of advice that, that we could give is, um, yeah, don't do concurrency unless you absolutely have to. And, uh, even then really try not to do it yourself. Like, uh, for example, let's say you need something that reads a thousand files and, uh, um, you know, let's say, you know, does some transmutation of those files and creates 1,000 new files that are slightly different, right?
那是不理想的，因为加法运行得非常快，除非你有大量的加法要做，比如我只有五个加法，但我把它们放在五个不同的线程里去执行，那么开销成本就会占据主导地位，因为要完成的工作量实在太小了。是的，完全正确。我们能给出的最大建议是：除非绝对必要，否则不要使用并发。即使必须使用，也尽量不要自己动手。比如，假设你需要读取一千个文件，并对这些文件进行某种转换，生成一千个略有不同的新文件，对吧？
You know, you could, you know, it makes sense. Like, you could use a thread pool and you could have all your cores reading these files and all of that. But something way, way easier is just write a program that reads one file and creates one output file and then use a new parallel. So if you're on Unix, you could type the word parallel. That's actually your program. And so it takes a little bit of time to learn how it works, especially if you need to read a bunch of files and you need to create output files that are the input file name dot data or something like that.
你可以使用线程池，让所有的核心去读取这些文件，这确实有道理。但有一个简单得多的方法，就是写一个程序，读取一个文件并创建一个输出文件，然后使用 GNU Parallel。如果你在 Unix 系统上，你可以输入“parallel”这个词，这其实就是一个程序。学习它如何工作需要一点时间，特别是如果你需要读取一堆文件，并需要创建文件名类似“输入文件名.data”这样的输出文件时。
It's a little bit of exercise in learning how that works. But it lets you write programs that are just very small and simple. And they'll run, GNU Parallel will run as fast as your computer can run. And they have all sorts of different tricks to speed that all up. And there's just Bash is doing all the parallelism for you. On OS X, you have to use Homebrew and Brew install parallel. I don't think it's on by default. But you could just do
学习如何使用它需要一点练习，但它能让你编写非常小巧简单的程序。GNU Parallel 会让程序运行得和你的计算机极限速度一样快。它还有各种各样的技巧来加速这一切，Bash 会为你处理所有的并行化工作。在 OS X 上，你必须使用 Homebrew 安装 parallel，它默认是不安装的。但你只需要执行
that and now you have it there too. So yeah, Gadoo parallel and writing something that just does one file will eliminate most of the parallelism. Also, there's a lot of async libraries. For example, we've mentioned Node.js on the podcast. If you're using, let's say, Express, which is a web server library in Node.js, they do all the parallelism for you. So basically, you just create handlers. So you say, look, when someone comes to my website and they enter this URL, like slash me, then I want to go and fetch their account and print it. And, you know, that handler can get called, you know, 10 times from 10 different threads. And you don't even have to manage those threads or anything. It's all done for you.
那个命令，现在你也就拥有它了。所以，使用 GNU Parallel 并编写只处理单个文件的程序，就能消除大部分并行化的复杂性。此外，还有很多异步库。例如，我们在播客中提到过 Node.js。如果你使用 Express（Node.js 的一个 Web 服务器库），它们会为你处理所有的并行化。基本上，你只需要创建处理程序。比如，当有人访问我的网站并输入这个 URL（如 /me）时，我想去获取他们的账户并打印出来。那个处理程序可能会被 10 个不同的线程调用 10 次，你甚至不需要管理这些线程，一切都为你做好了。
So almost every web server library does that part for you because they know how difficult it is. So, yeah, the last thing I would mention is basically in your algebra systems, so BLAS systems like PyTorch and NumPy and SciPy and these other systems, under the hood, they're doing multi-threaded. So basically, you know, if you say NumPy.add A and B, A and B are matrices. Under the hood, it's going to use all the cores of your computer. It's going to have a thread pool. It's going to spin up all these threads.
所以几乎每个 Web 服务器库都会为你处理这部分工作，因为他们知道这有多困难。最后我想提的是，在你的代数系统中，比如 PyTorch、NumPy 和 SciPy 等 BLAS 系统，它们在底层都在进行多线程处理。基本上，如果你执行 NumPy.add A 和 B，A 和 B 是矩阵，底层会使用你计算机的所有核心。它会有一个线程池，并启动所有这些线程。
It's going to even do like SIMD and all of this stuff. But you don't have to have to do with any of that yourself. You just say add. So even PyTorch has the multip-processing module, or we talked about Julia in a past episode. You know, a lot of these libraries will even do multi-processing or even multi-machine. PyTorch has Torch.distributed for multi-machine. And you don't have to really mess with any of that threaded code. It's all abstracted away, and that will work for 99% of use cases. All right. So yeah, I think the other piece of advice is definitely do a lot of logging make sure my last piece of advice is make sure
它甚至会使用 SIMD 等技术，但你完全不需要自己处理这些。你只需要调用 add。即使是 PyTorch 也有多进程模块，或者我们过去提到的 Julia。很多这类库甚至会进行多进程处理，甚至是多机处理。PyTorch 有用于多机处理的 Torch.distributed。你根本不需要去处理那些线程代码，一切都被抽象化了，这适用于 99% 的用例。好的，我认为另一个建议是：一定要做好日志记录。我的最后一个建议是确保
that when you log you log the thread so you can actually usually get the pointer to the thread object or something like that that way you can kind of tell your threads apart and yeah definitely start small write lots of tests unit tests
在记录日志时，记录下线程信息，通常你可以获取线程对象的指针之类的东西，这样你就能区分不同的线程。一定要从小处着手，编写大量的单元测试
and things like that if you have threaded code because you're amplifying the amount of errors and also the the effect the penalty of having an error is amplifying man we had all this interesting conversation and then we just basically said and try not to do any of this that's great yeah exactly i, people have to do it for you. I mean, like the Eternal Terminal thing that I wrote is full of threads. So in your career, it'll be very hard to get out of it. So our advice is don't do it if you can help it. But both Patrick and I do multi-threaded code regularly.
以及类似的东西，如果你有线程代码的话，因为你放大了错误的数量，同时也放大了错误带来的代价。天哪，我们进行了这么多有趣的对话，最后却说“尽量不要做这些”，这太棒了。是的，确实如此。人们必须为你做这些。我的意思是，我写的 Eternal Terminal 就充满了线程。所以在你的职业生涯中，很难完全避开它。所以我们的建议是：如果能避免就不要做。但 Patrick 和我确实经常编写多线程代码。
So you won't be able to get away with it all the time. Well, I look forward to probably not seeing any of you on the Discord. Well, we just announced it like an hour ago. Oh, because you're Patrick. I thought, okay. Yeah, Patrick is going to go into recluse mode now you had your opportunity two hours four five there's like four there's three three people who uh drop by so there we go or four people that's right so you three people got a rare exclusive chance to see patrick actually engage in a in some type of multi-user forum. But mostly you could actually just be streaming this to them
所以你不可能总是能避开它。好吧，我期待着可能在 Discord 上见不到你们任何人。我们才刚刚宣布了一个小时。哦，因为你是 Patrick。我以为……好吧。是的，Patrick 现在要进入隐居模式了。你们有两个小时的机会……有三个人路过，所以就这样吧，或者四个人。没错，你们三个人得到了一个难得的独家机会，看到 Patrick 真正参与某种多用户论坛。但其实你完全可以只是向他们直播这个过程，
and pretending like I was live. That's true. All right, catch you later. The intro music is Axo by Vynar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
假装我是直播的。确实。好的，回头见。片头音乐是 Vynar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。